good morning hank it's tuesday it's
question tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
and i say we
because i'm joined by ashley c ford
best-selling memoirist and my friend
it's called somebody's daughter it's out
now it's so great what is your opinion
on seagulls
i am not a fan me neither one of them
has chased
my husband yeah down a beach he is
handsome
he is very handsome
how does it feel to have oprah love your
book when you've been
outside all day and it's been really
really cold and you take off all of your
wet soggy clothes
and you get into the perfect hot shower
that's what it feels like wasn't it
amazing even though there were a lot of
people who were like in the comments
like hey oprah where'd you get that
quilt
tomorrow as this is uploaded yes you can
see
ashley c ford in conversation with oprah
winfrey
live in person on zoom
wait what is somebody's daughter about
somebody's daughter
is about my girlhood growing up with
difficult parental situation um
my mom had some emotional
uh issues and we had some interactions
that were not super fun
and the whole time my father was
incarcerated
um so just talking about dealing with
that
talking about the feelings that come
from that and
the hope that i can make it to the other
side when does the worry about releasing
a book end and the relief set in
you tell me what's it been like coming
home to indiana after so much time in
new york
perfect what would you say to a young
person living with trauma or what do you
wish someone had said to you
i wish someone had said to me that there
is no such thing as a bad feeling
that my anger sadness
frustration i wasn't being punished when
i was having that kind of feeling
and i also wasn't doing anything wrong
part of what makes
trauma often so difficult is not knowing
when or how it will end and not seeing a
way out of it
um and just because you cannot see when
or how something will end
doesn't mean it won't end i had somebody
explain emotions to me one time as like
little tunnels
that you walk into and they curve
and so because of the curve you can't
see the light
necessarily for a long time when you're
walking into that tunnel
but eventually as you follow that curve
you see the light and you can walk
toward it
but a lot of people have been either
taught or shown by example to stop
in the middle of that tunnel and that's
just not gonna work for processing
emotions you gotta go through it but
there's always a way out
what is powerful about memoir as a means
of expression
memoir in and of itself asserts
that every single person
every human life also has a story what's
your favorite thing about the midwest
driving on back roads past cornfields
way too fast
listening to yacht rock like christopher
cross ride like the wind that's got
michael mcdonald in the background
i can't get into the michael mcdonald
that's okay
and i feel bad my michael mcdonald
impression yes
i keep forgetting
wow i'm gonna give everybody the secret
really quick if you want to do a michael
mcdonald impression for anybody
yeah all you have to do is yawn and sing
at the same time oh i wonder if that's
how he does it if he's like
it's okay it's three in the morning time
to get to work time to hit the studio
ashley's book somebody's daughter is
available wherever books are sold it is
such a special extraordinary book
ashley thank you for being here and also
for being the first guest in our house
in 15 months
thank you for having me hank we will see
you on friday